okay so umbrella academy season three
ends with a big cliffhanger that seems
like it's raped right out of the ending
of bike club even the final shots are
set up in the same way and if you're
here it probably means you have no idea
what's going on while you're in luck you
chump as throughout this video we're
going to be going over the biggest wtf
questions to give you some clarity on
what exactly is happening in the show
spoiler alert
yes that is too good not to use again
and if you like the video then please
hit the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
umbrella academy season three
okay so the first big question i think
we need to talk about is who is sir
reginald hargreaves well in the series
we have had hints towards his backstory
and season one's final episode opened
with him at his wife abigail's side as
she lay in her deathbed season two
showed us that he's in fact an alien and
this opening scene in 10 was actually
his home planet he said farewell to
abigail and took with him not only a jar
of orbs that he opened up but also a
white violin that he later gifted to
victor now in the comics we get some of
what happens after this fleshed out when
we read more about the character we
discover that his home planet was dying
along with his wife and that he set out
amongst the cosmos in his private
bessela minerva this was with his
private bodyguard abhishad who doesn't
feature in the show and instead a lot of
his role is shifted over to pogo on
earth hargreaves invested in several
businesses he became a nobel prize
winner and also an olympic gold medalist
in season two when the family traveled
back in time we discovered that he
teamed up with a majestic 12 a group of
illuminati-esque people who had some
basis in the real world the illuma wadi
for decades now there's been conspiracy
theories surrounding the mysterious
members that make it up and they're
meant to be a number of high-ranking
scientists military leaders and
government officials according to the
rumors they control world events and
also hide the existence of ufos the
group was apparently formed all the way
back in 1947 under the orders of
president truman and after recovering an
alien spacecraft they began to cover up
the truth from humanity they and
hargreaves worked together for a long
time and he helped them in several
technological advances which is when he
became so involved in the space race we
discover in season 2 that he's
attempting to reach the dark side of the
moon which we learn the reason for in
season 3. turns out that abigail is
there and i believe that his ship
crash-landed on earth after dropping her
there which is why he was desperate to
get back she may have been shut out in
an escape pod-esque station which we see
luther was put in charge of guarding now
hargreaves ended up severing ties with
the group after he discovered that they
were complicit in the assassination of
jfk after that he went into somewhat
obscurity formed the academy and enacted
the next part of his plan now i believe
that the hotel itself might actually be
his down ship when the environment
transforms around it it seems like some
kind of vessel with a cockpit inside of
it i think that hog reeves plan was to
reset the universe and he wished to
unleash the orbs let them get absorbed
into women in order to create life take
these children nurture them until they
matured and then used them as a way to
power up the machine this would then
allow for the universe to restart so
that he could be with abigail this
explains why he got involved with the
space race tried to get to the dark side
of the moon and also trained the academy
however it might also be possible that
you can just sacrifice lives in order to
start it up but adding the orbs into it
explains why the seven members at the
end don't need to die in order for it to
be charged i think that the vessel
carried its own defense mechanisms in
the guardians and that this stopped him
from accessing the ship which is why he
sent in the soldiers he put forth a
number of them but all of them were
wiped out and thus he decided to train
the umbrella and sparrow academy so that
they'd be strong enough to take them on
in the training session we see they're
literally fighting over a bell on the
floor which foreshadows the seven bells
that he talks about them having to ring
we also learned that there were 43 women
who ended up giving birth to the
children with special abilities and that
he tried to adopt all of them however he
only managed to get seven making me
think that he wanted backups just in
case the others either left or died now
he originally tried this with the
umbrella academy but judah ben passing
away and number five disappearing they
slowly started a fracture and eventually
the group split thus he ended up taking
his own life in order to bring them back
together for his funeral my guess is
that he had put the pieces in place so
that they'd discover the hotel and then
they themselves would end up powering
the machine up with the universe being
reset through that this would then bring
him back to life and then he could carry
out his own plan however things went
awry and after the apocalypse happened
they had to travel back in time this
eventually led to them meeting
hargreaves and after he realized that
they weren't the kind of students he
could train he started to track down
others this was basically his end game
and hulk greaves is really the villain
of the show with his ultimate goal being
to reset the universe so that he can be
with his wife judging by the final scene
it seems like they rule over the entire
world and that the pair have their
fingers in every form of industry with
her at his side he's likely changed the
face of the planet and will probably be
the big bad come the next season now his
plan to restart the universe would have
happened either way with or without the
apocalypse we discovered that project
oblivion is something that he wanted to
carry out for a long time and that it's
the reason pogo ended up leaving his
employment this was a suicide mission
and discovering this is also why the
sparrows decided to medicate him so that
he couldn't manipulate them into doing
it klaus stopping him from taking his
pills allowed the character to get back
into his proper frame of mind and he
ended up manipulating him for most of
the season he apparently became a good
father and this made claus try and win
in favor with the family once more
hargreaves then planted the idea on
their heads about resetting the universe
and he killed luther to unite the group
this was his plan all along and it
didn't really matter if there was a
kugel blitz or not and that kind of
leads us into my next question which is
why was the kugelblitz created well this
ties into holland killing the mothers of
the umbrella academy after he ended up
getting his own special abilities he
said he felt them upon his mother's
death however he couldn't control his
powers unless he killed all their
mothers instead this meant that they
were never born and thus if they were
never born then they could never have
created the new timeline by traveling
back in time and then traveling back to
the future to be part of it because it's
a lot of timely whimey wibbly wobbly
stuff now though we don't know exactly
how pogo goes out he was killed along
with the reality as were all the other
characters that don't make it through
the portal normally the commission would
have kept things in check but as we know
they were wiped out too now we actually
discovered that five ended up creating
the commission which again is a bit of a
head
five states that he doesn't remember
doing this and therefore it could be his
future self rather than being a variant
i think that it has to be a version of
him from later down the line as he tells
him to not stop the apocalypse and he
also says oblivion which is of course
hinting towards the hotel just in case
you don't know that's the true name of
the hotel and this was revealed in the
aptly titled third volume hotel oblivion
now the other questions you probably
have over the ending are how did luther
come back to life though he would have
returned in the reset he showed back up
at the hotel along with klaus i believe
that this is the next evolution in
klaus's powers and just in the same way
that he can return to the land of the
living i believe those trapped on the
other side can be brought back too early
on the season was very much about him
mastering his abilities and this is
likely the next step now i'm reading
your mind mate i'm do i'm doing a
professor x out here and not only do you
want to subscribe but you also don't
want to ever unsubscribe either on top
of that you're wondering if sloane
exists in this reality the answer is a
mystery but i'm leaning towards yes due
to everyone being returned and all their
wounds being healed however she should
have come back in the elevator as she
was at the hotel so potentially this
machine might have sacrificed her there
is the possibility that sloane would not
have existed in a new timeline if the
umbrellas had been born so she might
have actually been wiped out in order to
not cause another paradox it's strange
she's the only one not there especially
as we get a second version of ben who
shows up in the credit scene this is
another i'm reading your mind mate wait
what what did you say about my mother
anyway this is another question that you
likely have well to get into it there
actually exists two versions of ben in
the franchise the first version is the
initial one who was with the umbrellas
that died as a child he became a ghost
but his spirit was put to rest in the
second season however when they went
back in time and changed things ben was
altered too neither harlan or hargreaves
met him because he was a ghost and
therefore his mother wasn't killed and
he was seen as being someone who could
be selected by reginald so this
sparrowation exists but so does the
original one because he wasn't killed
after the universe was reset the only
person who doesn't seem to be affected
by anything is alison who still has a
bandage on her arm showing that she
hasn't healed because she is the one
that pressed the button inside what i'm
guessing is the cockpit she likely was
protected from the effects remember this
was designed by hargreaves so that he
could be with his wife and he likely
didn't want to lose the memories he had
of her with the universe reset it's
possible that the one we see ruling over
everything actually has no idea that his
plan worked and rather than living
peacefully with his wife he's decided to
do this because he didn't know the
alternative putting himself at the top
like this would make him and abigail a
target for people that want to overthrow
him and if this was the plan all along
to get her back i don't think he'd go
through with it if he had any memory of
what had come before now another
question of alison is what's up with rey
he returns at the end to be with her and
it appears that the pair finally got
their happy ending in the present now
i've kind of gone back and forth on this
and there are really three outcomes the
first is that he was transported to the
present after allison pressed reset like
my mate used to when i was beating him
on smackdown however this would cause a
paradox and if they want to go for the
fourth apocalypse in a row then him
being in the future could be the cause
of it he would have only have been
brought forward if they went back in
time but they couldn't have gone back in
time without the
never mind now getting too confusing now
the second option is that the person who
presses the button gets their hearts
desires in this new universe and that
all the rules go out the window in order
to make it work this would mean he's her
child's father now and that there are no
paradoxes created the third version and
one that i think might be the most
likely is that he's a hallucination
throughout the series allison has had
several of them and i think that's the
most likely case here anyway that's all
the major ones but if you have any other
questions below then make sure you drop
them in the comments we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once on the 15th of july and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the show we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breaking of the
series which will be linked on screen
right now you talk a bit more in depth
about it and some of the questions that
we don't cover here so definitely go
head over there right after this by the
way thanks for sitting through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace